welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm Jesse Weber and thanks for joining
us the trial of Alec Murdoch the now
disgraced former attorney charged with
killing his wife and son is likely to
stretch on much longer and that is
because the jury is now hearing
testimony about Murdoch's apparent
corruption on Tuesday jurors heard for
the first time about Murdoch's finances
leading up to June 7th that's when
prosecutors allege Murdoch killed his
wife Maggie and Son Paul to distract
from his alleged misdeeds now typically
testimony like this wouldn't be allowed
in because Murdoch is only charged with
fraud he hasn't been convicted of it but
here the judge determined that the state
could bring it in because it is so
closely intertwined with other things
going on in Murdoch's life in the summer
of 2021. lawyers are now indicating that
because the jury will need to hear the
same testimony that the judge in court
watch Court Watchers already heard the
trial is going to last at least another
week now some of the most damning
Witnesses are those who worked alongside
Murdock at his law firm in fact when
prosecutor computers asked a former
colleague who had known Murdoch for
decades what he was like well this is
what she had to say
what were your observations of him as a
lawyer
I think Alec
um
was successful more up not from his work
ethic but from his ability to establish
relationships and to
to manipulate
people into settlements and clients into
liking him
um so he did it through the article
basically
that can be an art
uh did he in your estimation in your
judgment was he more of a technical type
lawyer or is he one that really
understood how to use the emotion of the
case he would use the emotion of a case
in the in the emotion of his clients
no mincing words there I'm drawn by my
co-hosts legal experts public defender
Brian buckmeyer former trial Attorney
Terry Austin Brian it seems like it is
one bombshell after another in this
trial so far you think the defense is
going to put on a Case what would that
case even look like from the defense
well Jesse first I thought the art of BS
was a good thing for a defense attorney
but I guess it's bad but the defense is
going to have to counteract that don't
forget in opening statements they came
out saying that Alec is a good guy he
loves his family he loves his wife he
loves his son now these Financial crimes
and some of the background uh
information that we're seeing here
they're going to have to contradict that
in the case it's another battle another
front that they're going to have to push
back on the prosecution's narrative I'm
expecting them to get Witnesses who
actually liked him who said he was a
good guys and he was generous trying to
create this facade or this image that
he's not the type of person to commit
this crime because while the
prostitution bring in the financial
crimes they still can hang their hat on
this is not the type of person he is but
they've got to prove it well what about
Terry how the defense did on a cross
exam domination of the CFO they make any
points at all well they made some minor
points but I have to say secondary was
definitely on point and as you saw
during that clip she did not mention any
words but I think the cross-examination
made a couple little points he started
out by saying look they're all these
frauds but those are going to be
separately tried in other Criminal
Courts and she had to admit yes that's
the case and he did state that the
murder occurred June 7th and when she
started investigating everything she
basically waited until September to do
all of the thorough investigation of
those crimes why did she wait so long he
implied that something was amiss at that
point and then she found that in 2011
all of these misdeeds happened and
nobody caught any of it so he was trying
to imply that the firm was allowing it
to incur all right it's an argument look
we're going to continue to follow this
Murdoch trial bombshell development
every day lot to cover there
[Music]
hey welcome back everybody a
Massachusetts mother was arraigned on
murder charges Tuesday from her hospital
bed Lindsey Clancy may have been
suffering from postpartum psychosis when
she allegedly strangled her children her
five-year-old daughter and
three-year-old son died the night of the
attack while the seven month old died a
few days later at a hospital Clancy's
husband Patrick says that he'd been
working from home to help out but went
to pick up food and when he got home he
found her outside Apparently after she
jumped from a second story window in an
attempt to die by Suicide during
Tuesday's hearing the judge decided not
to set a monetary bail saying Clancy is
a minimal Flight Risk the prosecutor
walked the court through what 9-1-1
dispatchers heard when Patrick found the
children in the basement
he can then be heard screaming in agony
in shock as he found his children his
screams seemed to get louder and more
agonized as the time passes
Cora and Callan were on the floor in the
den area of the finished basement which
is to the left when you walk down the
stairs
while Dawson was alone on the floor in
his father's home office which is to the
right when you go down the stairs
each child still had the exercise bands
that was used to strangle them tied
around their necks when their father
found them
Dawson and Kellen were face down on the
floor
Cora was on her side with her torso
turned towards the floor
he removed the bands and begged them to
breathe
he continued to scream uncontrollably
and screamed for officers to come to the
basement the dispatchers are hearing
this and they sent help down to the
basement and when they encounter Patrick
he yells out she killed the kid
it's just awful uh Brian how can Clancy
be a rain though if the attorney
believes she may have postpartum
depression or psychosis so Jesse there's
a slight difference between the
competency to progress through a
criminal case and a potential Insanity
defense competency just says do you
understand who your lawyer is and what's
going on in the case that doesn't seem
to be the question here well they're
probably going to do with Clancy is
going to evaluate her to see if at one
point in time specifically at the time
of these charges or crimes was she
suffering from probably postpartum
psychosis depression might not give them
what they want but postpartum psychosis
could help in explaining or mitigating
the allegations against her well Terry
Lindsay was prescribed multiple
medications which apparently affected
her murder Behavior you think the
physician has any criminal or legal
civil exposure yeah I mean we've seen
this kind of thing happen in the past
where a doctor prescribes a patient too
much of a particular medication and here
the husband actually said to the doctors
look she's acting like a zombie and if
in fact for medical malpractice The
Physician did not go by the standards of
that practice area then it could be
medical malpractice it could be
negligence if he caused the injury and
if that medicine caused the injury to
the patient and she injured herself and
clearly she did hear and her children
there could be some viable claim against
the physician just a horrible horrible
horrible story to think about and now
the question is how did this happen so
it's something that we'll continue to
monitor well there's another case on our
radar out of Broward County Florida we
want to talk about three men began trial
on Tuesday in the 2018 shooting death of
rising rap artist
xxxtentacion the rapper's real name is
Jose onfroy he was 20 years old when he
was gunned down at a motorcycle
dealership in Deerfield Beach on for I
went to the dealership with a man named
Leonard Kerr who told investigators that
the rapper was shot while driving out of
the dealership parking lot in fact Kerr
said that on Freud's vehicle was cut off
by a black SUV and two gunmen got out
and demanded property from onfroy they
later opened fire on the wrapper and
stole a designer bag that had cash and
the rapper's personal belongings
investigators say defendants Michael
boat Wright and Trayvon Newsom are
responsible for the shooting for
shooting on Freud while Dietrich
Williams drove the getaway car a fourth
co-defense that Robert Allen pleaded
guilty to second-degree murder and
robbery with a firearm and plans to
testify against the other men the three
co-defendants life faced life in prison
on first-degree murder and other charges
opening statements happened Tuesday
afternoon so let's take a listen to how
each side is laying out their case
as
Jose is there unarmed
in the driver's seat surprise
by the two gunmen in this case you'll
hear how they start struggling with him
punching him
and that both of the gunmen at one point
are trying to get his property from him
they're able to wrestle away from him
the Satchel that had the fifty thousand
dollars in cash
and without any provocation
without any type of weapons or anything
being used by the victim you'll hear how
Michael Bolt Wright fires several times
killing the victim at close range police
ignored
an extraordinary amount of evidence that
Michael was not the killer a day after
his arrest Mike BSO searches Michael's
home they go through that home with a
fine-tooth comb they pull out a whole
bunch of stuff from the home
they do not find
murder weapon they do not find lots of
money none of that has any of Jose on
Freud's DNA